astrology was my hard point i used it as
social
as my social tool when i wanted to get
to know people at the coffee house it
was hey what's your sign i know it
sounds cheesy
right but it works people talk
and they're like oh you know and people
people that are less or less christian
were more excited about it so i can
gauge where they were
oh interesting is astrology just
fun and games or is there a darker side
to it
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome to
led live where we will use the light of
christ
to expose some darkness and today's
topic we're going to get into
well we're going to get into outer space
a little bit
i think uh welcome michael michael moore
now you know there's a filmmaker michael
moore right
yes does everyone get you confused with
him no i clearly don't look like him
are you a filmmaker at all no okay not
at all
so um before we get into this topic very
interesting topic
you had a little bit of a run-in with
astrology did you guys ever
look into that or follow that or do you
even know what your
astrological sign is yeah well you know
i'm from mexico
and over there i mean it's very into
that kind of stuff like you know what is
your
signs and uh and all the stuff
and maya's like uh libra so believe it
or not me i grew up a christian but you
know
one once in a while you go to the to the
newspaper you know
you speak why am i acting like this well
it's because it says this in the
newspaper i can't leave the house
because my horoscope told me this yeah i
never
lived by it you know of course i know
that i'm a scorpio and
uh i think when myspace was around it
was like
embedded on everybody's page so you
would see it or something a lot and
it was it was interesting like sometimes
i'd be like wow that really is like me
but i never was like
oh i gotta read it today or whatever but
i remember even as a kid
at the grocery store there was always
like these little scrolls
do you guys remember those yeah little
scrolls you find your gas station
scrolls
yeah yeah those are very interesting i
lived in los angeles for 10 years
and so um everybody's into it there
and i remember people at friends of mine
would actually say oh yeah don't don't
date that girl she's a gemini
and they don't mix well with you you
know like that's what determines whether
you would like want to hang out with
somebody or not but
i never really got into it um i know a
little bit about it so i'm kind of
excited to get into this topic yeah yeah
but before we get into your testimony
what what i love this shirt man what's
what's with this
oh tell me the history of it i started
looking for hoodies that had bible
quotes on it because i was looking for
things because i'm kind of a colorful
person i like to wear things that are
out there and bright and so i was
looking for something that suited my
character that had you know
something that i could still glorify god
with and
so i found this on templaran.com
and they have hoodies that they were
able to
i was able to mix and match what i liked
i was able to put on
um i was able to put have the prayer was
on the front
but they had customized the back for me
oh cool so
you are the one that actually told them
to put this on there
and design it yeah yeah i mean
i think it's really cool because i we we
also have a passion for sort of wearing
your witness right yeah
like a roman's one right i'm not ashamed
of the gospel
put it on my outside so that people can
see it so i like that
that you're just i mean you do not
mistake you as
you know a believer in christ right
right and that's what i kind of
think is really neat uh yeah you had uh
brought up a couple of these so i don't
know if you guys can see this
out there but i don't know i just think
this is kind of cool
you know it's like we're engaged in this
warfare and this is putting it right out
there i like the front of this one it
says
uh not today satan yeah
i always thought that was kind of a neat
uh saying but uh yeah
check out this uh we'll put a link to
the description on where you guys can
get these
kind of an interesting company um
but i like it i like it wear your
witness man
very cool yeah i've always been kind of
a nerd and so
it kind of went well when i joined the
military because that
that nerdism developed into an actual
warrior culture
and so being that i was named michael
i was always very interested in saint
michael yeah
and so that kind of led me into that
always wanting to be the good guy the
warrior the and
then you find out later that that's the
patron saint of uh
of police and military which is exactly
what i was oh interesting
so give us a little background
start with your childhood like you know
were you raised in a religious family
uh i was okay tell me a little bit about
that um well i was ra
i was raised as a catholic my
grandfather's a deacon
in michigan and my grandmother was the
church lady
from saturday yeah we often reference
that
could it be doing that could have been
but that's that's how we actually made
that joke a lot when it came to
talking about grandma you know i love
your grandma yeah yeah
and there was um
there was a lot of real pressure to be a
part of the church
my mom is seven of nine children oh wow
and i'm the oldest of seven
and so i was supposed to be the leader
yeah i was the leader everybody had to
had to follow me so it was a lot of
pressure for me and i really i really
didn't like
being the leader because i didn't like
my siblings copying me
really young age i got really too much
pressure oh right no it was more or less
when i when i was a teenager throughout
high school i was always
accused of being a poser oh yeah and so
i was really i was always
i didn't like being unoriginal and so
having
little siblings copy me i was like no
right but you know that's a that's an
actual form of
complimentary if somebody's copying what
you're doing
um i think that's kind of they say it's
the highest form of flattery yeah
no as i got older it became something
that i wanted more of to actually help
them out but
when i look back at how i was that's
what really made me not want to you know
i was a terrible big brother
and you know i see all the things that i
actually led them down and seeing how
they came out i'm like i wonder
if it had been different had i been
different interesting interesting maybe
that's perhaps
why god made the firstborn he
basically says the firstborn is mine
and the firstborn of the animals was
also supposed to be the lord's
which i thought was interesting yeah
maybe because he knew that that was
you know a strong position in the family
right and that that
would lead and dictate sort of how the
outcome of the other siblings would come
right it makes you wonder with cain and
abel yeah very true
very true and i know that uh was it the
the firstborn male is supposed to be the
head
how of the priest's house the household
priest that's right and so he was
supposed he had a leadership and
authority
along you know god given leadership and
authority along with you know
obvious genetics and so
it made it really
for me when i started moving forward
with my life away from
the rest of my family and into my own
household in hopes that your
walk could be a witness to your younger
siblings and they'd be like oh i've seen
all the mistakes he made
i'm gonna follow his path now because i
don't want to go through all that
right right right and i see a lot of my
siblings um
some of them are doing very good some of
them are doing poorly
and because you know there's a lot of uh
i get all of them most of them calling
me
and letting me know how they are some of
them don't want to really talk to me but
that that comes with family i i think
it's important to keep a line of
communication there even if maybe you
disagree on lifestyles no of course
whatever you know so
um all of us have i have a family member
as well that
really could care less about um you know
religion or god and
you know it it hurts as as an as an
older brother to him and it's like you
know you want
you want him to to be excited about
this thing you know that you see the
context of religion all the way around
you
and and it's like you know god forbid
we get to the end of the life and they
don't make that choice you know it's
like that
that that's going to be a hard thing for
us so you know definitely keep praying
for him
and keep that line of communication open
yeah my mom's a lot of inspiration with
that because
within this testimony i'm going to let
you guys know like my mom was an
integral part
of both of my conversions because i
first came
to general christianity in return and
then afterwards
i came to adventism what is your family
like at this point i mean are they going
to church all the time
i mean having a relationship with god
you have family worships
tell me a little bit about that family
worship not so much we started off
with the generality of you know church
is family
and so we we attended church every
sunday we went on
uh went on our holidays we had you know
the catholic holidays they had lent they
had
you know the different uh different
things that you would do
yeah ash wednesday it's hard for me to
remember now
because it's like i gotta go back and
think and like what were our holidays
but uh i ended up being an altar boy for
my grandfather
i ended up going through catechism um i
participated heavily in the youth group
that was more of my
my style at the time were you really
interested in it or were you just kind
of in it for the social
aspect it was a little bit of both i
really did have
enjoy a strong relationship with god i
think like it's like you're always
trying to seek that relationship you had
with god as a
child as an adult and i feel i'm always
like okay
you know i had a lot more belief when i
was younger and i think that's really
hard it's like i'm always trying to get
back to that place when i was a child
and i could just talk to god i'd walk
down the street and talk with him like
he was next to me
and it's more difficult for me to do now
as an adult well that's maybe why jesus
said that you know you must be as a
little child to enter into the kingdom
right that sort of just um you know
implicit trust that god is real and
and you can talk to him and you know
it's as easy as that
like you see a faith of a child and it's
very simple
but very profound right and it seems
like as we get older we complicate it
more
and we make it this thing that's you
know that's a very
difficult thing and you know salvation
becomes muddled and
all of a sudden it's like now you're
like oh it's too hard for me you know
right that actually was a really big
thing for me as a child as i was getting
into
religion and you know the catholic
teachings are well these are the prayers
you say this is how you say them
this is who you talk to if you have sin
this is you know you can bring it up to
the priest and
and those kind of things and that made
it difficult for me to understand the
you know the actual communication with
god
because i was like well why does god
want to hear this prayer over and over
again
why does god want me to say this exactly
am i going to make a mistake and is that
going to be a sin
is this sacrilege you know and a lot of
the priests
didn't have the answers for me a lot of
the answers were you know
thrown out on the the faith branch right
and
those kind of things made it so
i didn't understand how god was
what god was i was encouraged to read my
bible although it was never practiced
amongst the family
if we read the bible it was on a holiday
it was because it was easter because it
was christmas because it was something
that
i had you know we had an obligation to
do because it was the holiday that
celebrated that
is always the birth and the resurrection
story basically
is that because at church
you don't sit down and sort of read it
or what why
i don't understand why would you not be
interested in the bible
um is it discouraged to kind of read it
or is it just sort of taught that you
don't
you can't understand it so don't read it
oh no it's none of that it's actually
encouraged to be
read amongst the catholic church it's
just not something if you don't put it
into practice you don't end up doing it
right and so it's not emphasized in
practice there's no real you know like
within the church now there's
40 days of prayer there's hey let's uh
go through this part of this part of the
bible in this amount of time
and those are the kind of practices that
i didn't have growing up
where it was more of a studious thing
where i'm going through catechism i have
to know this
i'm going through catechism i have to
know this and it was
you know well do you know what that
means you know briefly touched on okay
as long as you know what it means we're
good
so but remember this know this and it
wasn't really
like i think the one thing that was
never really hit upon in the catholic
church
was witnessing witnessing was not a big
practice it was just kind of well people
will see how you live
right and i do i do still believe that
living is the best witness
right i just don't believe that it's the
only witness
right as as you can see you know as you
speak as
the way that you speak you know to be
that peculiar person in a strange land
i think it's really cool that god baked
into our christianity
or our journey as christians i should
say
the um the activity of witnessing um
when you study out the sanctuary message
you know you have those different
articles
um in this sanctuary the holy place i
mean one of those articles being the
seven branch candlestick
is a representation of the witness
aspect right and the you know the
um the table of incense is your prayers
and the table of showbread is your bible
reading right so as a christian
as you walk through this experience of
of getting closer to god
you have prayer witnessing and bible
study and i always
loved hearing it explained you can't
share something
with somebody that you don't know and so
i think it was really god's
way of baking into our faith in our walk
with like well tell somebody else
because when you share that with
somebody else it really will solidify it
in your own mind
yeah no i think that's good um well as
far as when i was growing up
here's my family here
and uh that's which one are you in here
i'm the blonde one
okay yeah the one that has died yeah i
guess i could have guessed the tallest
so uh that's most of my siblings at the
time
okay i think that's about a large family
all of them yeah
and that was actually in the catholic
church right there so at some point
you got an interested in astrology where
what age were you when i don't know you
started having questions did you start
doubting god or did you think maybe this
was of god or what got you into this
stuff
well the occult actually started with an
interest very young
as i'll start with the the video game
deluge
it's where that became you know
dracula's curse castlevania three
very first video game and it got me into
the fantasy realm it got me into magic
it got me into spells it got me into
monsters it got me into
things that were in mythology yeah
interesting and
mythology you know when you've got these
games that are based sourcely
on mythology it gets you interested in
mythology it makes you want to know
hey is that real could that be real
that's really cool if it is
you know and so you're sitting there
thinking you know what if there was a
cenotar
what if i could shoot fire out of my
hand those kind of simple things and
and it starts off as you know real
childish kind of comic book things
and the comic book you know just it
that's you know where you get into these
things where can i find more information
like this where can i find more things
like this
what can i do to you know there's my
caked face ninja turtles
yeah one thing people often try to
defend like well the movies don't change
me or that i'm not gonna
oh you think because somebody watched
harry potter they're gonna join a coven
or something
it's it's not like that's it's not like
that uh yeah but it's yeah it's like
quick and
sharp but think about it you're you're
interested in these
fictional fantasy things wouldn't it be
cool if
maybe it's real i mean that's that's
even more i mean
if you already like the fiction aspect
just imagine how much
more you would like it if it's reality
right i mean that's
the logical steps right there go from
fiction to reality
right and that's where it started with
these video games
got me ultimately interested in dungeons
and dragons
and so i'm playing dungeons and dragons
role playing as if it were real
in a alternate reality building my
character
and drawing myself into a world where i
like my character
in this game way better than i like
myself totally
so how was your end your you changed
your attitude
yeah because you know when you more into
that kind of stuff and
now you don't like the reality life and
i like this character
i mean there was some change in your
attitude
um sort of like as a kid you get you
know the obvious game rage the
frustrations over playing something like
hey leave me alone i'm in my world
i'm playing my game don't bother me and
that's you know a lot of that's where
that comes from
and then you're sitting there wanting to
get good in that game wanting to get a
high score or wanting to
get all the achievements and things like
that why because you want your character
to be
the best i remember we worked on a
project
that really opened up the topic of
sports i like
sports like like i played them always as
a kid
watched them as a as a teenager um you
know even been to sports games as an
adult
and um when we got asked to work on this
project
i was like no no god don't like ruin
this one for me you know like
all right i don't want to look into that
not everything's of the devil
right that's what we hear all the time
yeah
and the two guys that one of them that
was a pastor
he was actually um on his way for the
nfl
and in college he had a injury that
knocked him out of
the opportunity to really go pro right
and um then you know he basically was
like my life is over that
was my life i'm ready to commit suicide
and he
literally went to the edge of committing
suicide and then somebody got a hold of
his heart and he's now a
pastor and um so he's the one that asked
us to work on this project and it was
very interesting
listening to him talk about well in
heaven when are you
ever going to want to be better than
someone else
and i was like that's a hard ball to
swallow and i was like no
that's that's actually true and he's
like tell me when in heaven can you
imagine yourself
preventing someone from making a goal so
that you can be the best
and i was like man like like right there
you know it's like wow and and not to
say that i think playing
with a ball is evil you know what i mean
like like but just
these little tiny things shape our
characters
and if you're running around going i'm
better than you
it's the straightest of all time and of
course not a heavenly character
yeah the the having good sportsmanship
and things like that
it's it's not the sport itself
but the uh the competition that comes
with it yeah
that's true so you're kind of
you know getting involved in this
supernatural world
teenage mutant ninja turtles didn't they
have a lot of magic i don't remember
no not really it was just eastern
business right it really was it was
about the ninjutsu and about the
the kung fu and like all the different
you know martial arts with their
well how did how did the turtle become a
ninja
toxic goose bro okay wait that's not
magic the green
green
i remember seeing some of the movies
when i was a kid i just don't remember
if there was actually
sorcery and stuff in there right but you
notice that you know
they don't make like they i they have
one
game that i know they have one christian
game for nintendo oh yeah
the bible noah's ark yeah the bible game
yeah noah's ark is it the job to get the
animals on the air right
right seriously yeah oh wow and like
it's it
it's a silly game but when you play it
it doesn't put any aspect behind god it
doesn't glorify god it's just an
arbitrary game where you're moving
through a side-scrolling world
yeah and so it's like but with these
they get into the background
they get into the story the stories are
deep the stories are
you know gut-wrenchingly you know
heartfelt
so you're learning from playing this
video game you're learning about an
alternate world
so to say so i have a question for you
what do you think about
a video game that teaches a christian
concept
i mean i i think it can be done right
i don't think like we talk about just
because it's a moving picture doesn't
make it bad so if it's a moving picture
that you actually control
that's not bad either we we kind of do
the same thing with bible studies you
know like we're
looking at this verse do you agree i
mean if that was the game do you agree
yes or no you make it move yes or no
um yeah i almost think it like i i'm not
so against
the technology of playing a digital game
right you know what i mean like i don't
think that that's what makes it evil so
to say
but i'm just listening to you talking
you're saying i'm learning these things
from playing this video game it's like
deep and i'm
i'm getting all this info but what if
there was actually something where you
were actually learning something
positive
i mean somebody needs to create a video
game that teaches some nice
cool biblical truth in a cool way not
just
you know cheesy but in a cool way gospel
of the rpg
where you can actually play as the uh
the forefronters of the bible as david
or as you know
going through actual like bible history
like that would help you remember it
right it would put it in a story
you know i'd be all for it right maybe
it starts out with genesis
and and it says uh in the beginning god
said and multiple choice and you if you
choose the right one then it says let
there be light well you know how there's
always a story attached with the video
game right
that's exactly what i was thinking three
minutes you would see you'd see that
little side cut of eve taking a bite of
the fruit and then it'd be
and then and then you started as like
yeah because you know
assassin's creed's got adam and eve
instead of
treating it like it was a bad thing they
take the apple and it's like a good
thing you know so
that that's kind of being done but not
bringing that up that uh
brought me to like the peak the turning
point of where
it went from video games and d d to
actual occult practice
interesting and uh actually how old are
you at this point
i would say it was probably about 1617
okay and so when i was role-playing in d
i got into a different kind of
role-playing
it was one called a vampire the
masquerade
and it was a role-playing system where
it was modern day
and you they had different types of
vampires and the history of this
actually included the bible it said that
cain was the first vampire saying that
was the curse that was the mark that was
put on him so he couldn't die
giving him this undead eternal life
interesting and so i'm like wow you know
maybe
there's different things about the bible
that i don't know and then that got me
into the book of enoch
and then that got me into moving out and
looking into witchcraft
interesting so wait from the book of
enoch it
kind of like wet your appetite it looks
really deep into it
it really it's interesting i haven't
actually heard that before yeah it's
it's you're planting a seed of doubt in
and what the bible actually says or what
it means
and making it like i wonder if there's
some you know
esoteric type information in the bible
which is kind of like what happened to
me with ancient aliens
theory i was like oh so you know moses
was wandering around in a wilderness
following a pillar of
fire could it have been a spaceship and
they just described it as a pillar of
fire
you know because right right they often
talk about they call them cigar shaped
and it's glowing
okay that's a pillar of fire and a cloud
of smoke by day
is that space is that like a spaceship
exhaust that they're following
yeah i was like so maybe god sent
beings from another world to help you
know god uses entities like
he uses his angels to help humanity so
what if god used aliens to help lead
moses out of the wilderness i don't
believe this
that's what i was taught by ancient
aliens and when
i started thinking about that i was like
i was a christian saying
wow this maybe this is like a
misinterpretation and it was
cool to me right but that can yeah
knocking all kinds of stuff you know a
hard left and
that was the problem is that i didn't
have anybody who was biblically versed
to tell me no
this the bible says this no the bible
says this
when i asked questions nobody knew
nobody knew the answer like
i i'd asked my my grandfather i'd asked
the other priests in the church i would
ask you know
my mom my mom didn't really have a lot
of time she was working full-time jobs
taking care of seven kids
and so it was kind of like you know i
didn't have a real strong biblical
foundation
and that's where it led into hey let's
check this out maybe
maybe the mythology that is all not
concluded in the bible
has some truth to it see i think that's
where satan
has his best opportunity with with
getting you off track he understands if
you don't have a deep surface level of
of
understanding of religion or the bible
all he has to do is
attach one thought like what you were
saying
you know the bible says that you know
the pillar of fire is this but really
it's this alien ship so he's
he can't deviate totally from the story
yeah but he just attaches something to
where it's just slightly off and it
kicks you off
off kilter and i mean you hear this time
and time again that's why it's
new age movements yeah on this show we
really do hammer
i believe that our surety and rock
is literally diving into a relationship
through the word of god understanding
what it says
and and pray for that understanding like
god promises if we read the bible
and we're praying with an open heart and
an a
and a heart of truth that god will
show us what those things are and what
those things mean you know
and how you were talking about with the
aliens and everything like at
a young age i've had like my own
thoughts and theories that actually
somewhat you know have come to fruition
as far as knowledge
base when it's talking about how
you know how aliens are demons how you
know and when you look at the way that
aliens are drawn
depicted and put now like the way that
they describe
angels in the in the bible those are
some scary things
no wonder they looked at him and said
fear not every time they spoke to a
human
right don't be afraid chill it's okay
yeah i just got ten heads and six wings
and so with that it's like imagine what
the fallen angels look like
right imagine how they look
how scary they are because it says it
would mention
that you know if you look at all the way
that they're described with the wings
and the eyes and
the animals and the mammals body parts
and whatnot
that they're a testimony of creation
like it's like
all put together in like some of the
coolest and best creations god had
noticed there's lots of human parts on
an angel right there's wings
there's a lion's head you know things
like that on the different how do you
have more than one face that's really
cool
right right and then you know imagine
the way that uh the different designers
had uh for the aliens movie for instance
uh i can't remember his name
but uh he had designed yeah h.r geiger
he designed those things and you notice
this like a lot of those
are in like really dark um really dark
music
the art like tattoo artists are really
drawn to this
and it's very sexual in nature by its
creation
and so you wonder where did these images
come from
where do these ideas of little green men
of
you know the aliens like controlling the
water in in the abyss
things like that and all of it has you
know
it's more supernatural than anything and
everybody's like no you know
they just have like telepathy and they
can make things float and they can heal
you with the touch like e.t
but those all sound very miraculous to
me
right right right you know and i believe
this is how satan is
changing the world and prepping them for
the second coming
so when he comes and he's doing all
these miracles like these aliens
right it seems natural right right i
mean like like the x-men and
you know hey he's going to come and give
everybody power so that you can fight
the city coming from the sky
right right that's the thing was like
superheroes yeah it's like
if if all of a sudden a bean an a alien
bean shows up with superhero powers
let me think about how many generations
have been primed with superhero type
movies it's like gonna be like oh wow
it's real
oh wow this dude can shoot lightning
lightning bolts out his eyes jumping in
this ball yeah
let's follow this guy and so you can see
the deception being lined up
so you're starting to get into all this
like cold stuff and it's starting to get
like
you know deeper and darker yeah um so
where are you going with this
well it was keyed off when i
got into a relationship and it was a
high school sweetheart
and she was wiccan and so
i was still holding my faith i wasn't
like hey
i'm you're wicked i'm wicked no it was
more like you know trying to witness to
her trying to talk to her trying to tell
her about god
and then finally i finally convinced her
to come to church with me
wow wow i got her to come in the church
and it was a train wreck oh no they
treated her
miserably it was absolute judgment there
was no
love whatsoever like she came in with
her necklace and everything and she you
know and she got scowled she got nose in
the air kind of feeling like people
wouldn't talk to her wouldn't even shake
her hand
and i was disgusted i was absolutely
sickened by the church that i attended
and i'm like if this is what my god is
like i want nothing to do with him
oh wow and so that's when i started when
i turned my back on you know
on christianity wow and i started
heading down her path being like well
what do you got
wow and i started going like i went head
first because i went into everything
that
wasn't god because i'm like okay god is
caring god is love
let's see what god does when i jump on
the other side in the middle of the
street and see if see if he helps me
interesting interesting yeah let that be
a testimony to
christians that yeah i was just thinking
it's the way you act
we have to have the character of christ
when somebody comes in
dressed like a prostitute looks like
they've been on drugs
love on that person they are there for a
reason
the church is a hospital for sinners
amen
and to treat people like that is not
gonna win anybody man
right i mean they actually within
mistreating earth they lost
two yeah that's so true they don't
realize that that simple
comment or that simple stare or whatever
is gonna like actually have that kind of
result
i remember a pastor that that i did some
video work with
he always had these stories these great
stories and he had the story of a
prostitute walking into the church came
sat down on the front
and some little old lady walked right
over to her and said how dare you come
into this church with a dress on
like that what do you think that
prostitute did got up and walked out
never came back and it was like you know
i think that the little old lady was
was you know maybe thinking okay i need
to protect
the men that are here not thinking
where's this person
at right you know could there be a
better diplomatic way to
pull her aside or you know and i don't
know but but
love on them first figure out where
they're coming from right
and then pray about how to how to you
know approach that yeah and a lot of
times i you know myself included we have
a hard time figuring out uh
i'm not the holy spirit that's right
that's right
wow so you're getting darker and darker
into the
into the cold and so
i uh with the significant other i end up
having a child
at a very young age i was 18 when my son
was born oh wow
oh wow and you can see i've got my
zodiac sign around my neck there i'm
wearing the gemini symbol i got that
from the renaissance fair that year
and uh that became my new religious
symbol wow i was wearing that and it had
like a description of everything
gemini on the back and it just got
darker from there but you know
my hair started growing out i became
like every color in the rainbow at least
once
um i'd been wearing you know i'd steel
toe boots you know
spike collars you know i don't have eye
makeup
yeah no not lipstick okay lipstick but i
did take the eye makeup and make the
egyptian designs around my eyes and
everything and like make my eyes look
like the eye of raw as i would go out to
partying and
wow so from from the day that
happened when you brought her to church
i mean you never went back after that
no and then you started talking to her
like well what are you involved
or i mean just explain a little bit what
happened
after that like was it like i'm sorry
everybody treated you like that
um i was angry yeah i was so upset
and and i was upset at god i blamed god
for the way that his people treated
and that's you know i'm like this is
ridiculous i'm
i'm done with this church i'm done with
christianity and
let me see what you've got because what
you've got seems to bring you peace
wow man you know you don't realize like
just how
a soul can literally just make that
decision
in a moment like that and then just
their trajectory is set off in a totally
different
way and it's like well i'm going to
embrace satan then
i mean i i hear this story quite often
yeah
and then you're going to see the 20
years after you know it's
like a yeah for that decision for that
thing that you went over there
that look or whatever for those people
that came to the church for the first
time
and it was 20 years of darkness yeah
i mean maybe you know praise the lord
you came back right right but i said
why you need to have 20 years of cars
you know all these things from sand and
but and i can't take any credit for me
coming back
because when it comes down to it the
whole experience
is like i wasn't going to come back i
can tell you that right now
but i was literally spoken to by god in
a dream
wow and so i'll get to that yeah i'm
excited to hear that i want to
love the turning point yeah i want to
ask you about music
okay because you know uh you know
growing up you know
listening rock heavy metal and all stuff
i love the occultism
i love the dress like that right paint
my you know i used to have hair
you know grow up you know long hair
paint it you know
did you do the eye shadow no okay
that was too far it was too far yeah
yeah i used to like paint my nails black
and everything yeah i didn't do the
black i put the aussie
i put the some black stuff but no
crazy things but the thing is i'm asking
you because
into that kind of stuff for me music i
mean you need to have some
motive you know like a motto yeah dude
like pump you up you know this is what
drives music
that's right so i just want to ask you
that what kind of music i mean you know
i mean
well i mean it started off with what my
parents listened to and my parents
listened to like led zeppelin ac dc
that was what my dad listened to like my
biological father
he was all into the uh the classic rock
the the acid rock the
you know that kind of stuff and then my
mom was more into the love song she
liked michael bolton she liked uh
adams she liked uh what was the other
one
i can't think of his name yeah but uh
just
a lot of the love music was my mom my
mom was all about love like she would be
the one that would
i'd be sitting there watching tv or
playing a video game and she'd be
vacuuming the living room pick me up and
start dancing with me i'm like mom
yeah yeah that's sweet yeah praise god
for moms
right right amen and so uh
as the music went on it became it became
harder
it became darker ice you know it went
into
um rap where you know because being born
and raised in detroit you can't get away
from rap anywhere
right and so it was it you know
bone thugs and harmony right and you
know
just like yeah let me just start there
very
wicked really i mean they yeah they but
you kind of put off this like
like they are a christian or something
but i remember opening up that cd cover
and they're being uh complete like ouija
board
symbols and everything was written
backwards you had to read it with a
mirror
and it was this yeah there was a lot of
weird stuff oh man and and that
backwardsness i actually learned
about you know satan's backward language
from comic books
because i read uh doctor strange comic
books and doctor strange was all about
the occult
that's true in doctor strange if you
read in his comic books
his spells are just him speaking what he
wants to happen backwards
wow so if he's like you know making this
water come up and splash somebody
he's saying you know hey water
manipulation
backwards interesting and it's just you
know
you you think of things like that and
you wonder you know why words are spells
right spelling things like that you know
it's all got that same connection
where you know when i'll get into what i
was taught once i started getting into
it what i started with is what she was
into
and that was uh nordic with witchcraft
where she was all about you know
that's hera and you know thor and odin
and zu
zeus um how did she get into it parents
like what was her kind of entrance her
parents were kind of fair-weather
christians like they
they really didn't have a drive they
didn't really see go to church unless it
was on eastern christmas kind of deal if
that
and uh they really just kind of lived
for themselves
would you say perhaps maybe when parents
are like that the kids are seeking
something real
yeah and tangible and it's like i think
deep down inside we all want to connect
with
something greater than ourselves and so
you know if there's real power in the
witchcraft then i'm going to
gravitate towards that because i don't
see it in christianity right i think
that's kind of maybe a little bit of
reasoning
yeah and i would i would definitely
agree and i think i fell right into
witchcraft because
catholicism itself was ritualistic by
nature
and so the ritualism of historically i'm
like
i can do this i'm like this is this is
actually easy i can do this
well wow and so it gave me confidence to
be like
now i've got something of my own now
i've got something of my own that gives
me power very very right or so the devil
wanted me to think right
right right interesting interesting so
here's a
me with my full pentacle there i've got
my uh
my actual zodiac symbol fitted into it
it was a custom-made coin as you can see
with always with the custom because i
don't want to be i always want to be
original original oh gee
right and so it's like you know i'm
shaving the sides of my hair let my hair
grow down
and i'm wearing the soulfly hoodie hey
yeah soulfly that was
that was a confusion in itself because
they claimed to follow god
they claimed to worship christ and like
soulfly was a band yeah okay soulfly was
a band and it was characteristic of
getting back to the primitive
of religion that was actually what his
album was called back to the primitive
interesting and a lot of times they'll
have the drum circles and they've got
the tribal noises the yipping and the
whooping
and then you can hear them you know kind
of like chanting in the background and
it's like
you know like this is what christianity
was supposed to be in the primitive
times
i i remember um there was a friend of
ours that was
big into the christian rock band scene
in australia
and so i was curious about that not
being a musician myself
and i was like you know what was that
like and he was like dude there was so
much like
drugs and women and all this kind of
stuff and i was like
at the christian concert like seriously
and i was like oh yeah it was literally
like being a rock star
but you just have this different lyric
content
right right and you know they touch on
stupid things like that and
things like south park they make the
joke that making a christian song is
just like taking a love song and putting
jesus instead of baby
yeah wow that's true yeah that's
interesting
and it's you know it that was my
constant joke i'm like you know
christian christian music that's a joke
because i was like that's you know
that's it's not emotional it doesn't
touch anybody it's just a love song with
replacement words and you know i was
really i started off with
the rap and i moved into rock i started
with metallica
and so bone thugs and metallica were my
my hardcore points at that
and i moved into mega death from mega
death i went into like older metal
where it would get into classic metal
because that was more
i don't know respected so to speak and
so i'd be things like judas priest and
you know getting into the 80s and like
what was metal then and then trying to
dig into the history of that so i could
become more like it
when i when i got into rock and roll um
you know i grew up a christian
and and i definitely went into like a
heavy metal and and things like that
but judas priest was just like that's
way too far yeah
like that's judas man i know about that
guy
pantera yeah oh yeah pantera i was big
into pantera
i was playing guitar by the time i was
13 and so i was always trying to make
that music
and i was i was even trying to take the
video games that i played and put them
into the guitar and play those play
those tunes
another christian buddy and i we went to
a pantera concert and i should have
known
because they had this huge pentagram on
the stage
with 666 above it and like this anarchy
sign all over the
uh american flag and i mean we just were
like
oh you know but it was like dude these
guys are straight satanic
you know so some more to go on that
speaking of your rock concert at that
age
i went to my first ozfest concert
and that was eye-opening you're starting
to look a little bit like ozzy here
right right i mean you know not so much
with the british accent
you do what i can but uh when i went to
us fest it was as fast 2000
interesting and this i had a t-shirt it
literally had like
satan with the horns and the red and the
pentacle and the upside down bet in the
background with ozfest on it
and pantera was playing there wow
pantera was playing there ozzy was
playing their incubus
um so many other different bands um
i think oh that's what it was um
creed was there creed was known to be
christian
yeah yeah he was kind of a christian guy
they got booted off stage oh interesting
they just had a huge background knew
that he was christian no because of what
he said
on stage because he uh there's a huge
backdrop that showed christ like running
out
like after the crowd that was their
pride yeah that was their prop for their
for their
show they said you know
we don't want to be we want to be here
to inspire people we want to be here to
you know
help you guys really live we don't want
you leaving this place feeling evil
and the moment they said that everyone's
like boo and like that was just before
pantera
like after pantera went on pantera went
on and they were throwing out dime bags
of marijuana
shooters of jack daniels and condoms wow
you know you just gotta wonder when you
have such an opposing
spirit there i mean i believe in the
spiritual world i believe there's angels
there
yeah and it's like you're gonna come out
into their world
and be like you know follow jesus now my
hat goes off to creed
like to even have the um you know the
courage to be able to do something like
that
that takes a lot of courage but yeah
that's that's a
that's walking into the lion's den for
sure right let's get into that music
my first band wow the wired frog that
was not my band name that was the place
we were playing
i'm gonna be like it sounds like a
coffee shop it was a coffee shop
actually it was a coffee shop it had uh
two gay owners that we knew
we would uh we would go and we would
play there we were a metallica cover
band at that point in time
we were oh was the fan's name up
tortured souls
interesting yeah yeah and so we even had
this like imagery that we had set up
that each band member was some sort of
like part of a horror movie
where the guitar player was a vampire
the singer was kind of shackled
or the the drummer was shackled to his
drums like a zombie and then
you know just the bassist was the fallen
angel with the black wings
and all sorts of demonic things and
these are these are the creative things
that we come up with where we're
really trying to reach out and make a
gimmick yeah so to speak
right right i have a question about
music yeah i have my own
you know uh testimony all stuff but uh
music you know heavy metal and all stuff
what you were
what kind of music you would listen or
what kind of group you were listening
when
you had those moments that you have a
like a
like stressed a stressed day
or like you know what i'm sitting down
and
uh maybe you're like you know what i
just want to relax
what kind of music you were choosing
metallica you were
choosing soft rock oh no no when i was
rage against the machine
i mean when i went like relaxed yeah you
want to relax it's not like a party and
everything so that's what i said what
kind of music you would listen to
most of the time you wouldn't try to
relax you try to encourage your anger
by listening to disturbed or metallica
angry songs the ones that are like you
know
hey punch that guy in the face because
you know he made you mad
or this person you know mega death had a
lot of that
you know oh this person really peed me
off and you know
writing their songs and that kind of
stuff disturbed especially so disturbed
was big
and then with that if i really was
stressed out and wanted to relax
yeah i'd listen to like drum circle
music yeah and so it'd be like you know
i could
zone out i could forget about the world
around me and i could literally go into
a trance
yeah i'm asking you because you know i
remember you know when
i had just you know maybe like just
stressful
have a headache or i have this thing or
like you know whatever
but i didn't want to like like act to it
but just to like
close to myself but i was losing
metallica yeah
you know i was listening mega there i
was listening
i mean i was not acting like you know
what i'm saying yeah
but to me i was just just relaxing right
i used to like you know relaxing thing
but i was just listening to it it's just
observing that yeah but it's not like
you know what
i'm so stressful i want piano music you
know so like
no you didn't you didn't choose that you
know it's like listen the same thing
but i was you know you you actually was
not like
you know what i'm saying so i was
listening to more of the dark stuff that
wasn't so
angry like tool yeah i'd listen to a lot
of tool i'd listen to a lot of
uh the misfits i'd listen to you know a
lot of the punk and rock music
combined i'd listen to uh perfect circle
that was tool's side project that was
like the softer side of tool so to speak
and those kind of things were what i
would listen to to fall asleep to relax
that kind of stuff
i have an interesting tool thing because
i was kind of a follower of that band as
well
um i had a friend that worked for them i
think they had a studio in arizona
and um so i was kind of naturally
curious like
what was that like and he was like dude
they're so weird
like they would follow the 13th evil
horde of the
blah blah blah blah blah angels and you
know it was like wow yeah they're really
there
they'd have a little demon box the
drummer would would
put in his trap set and it was always
traveling with him and stuff like that
and it was
it was his demon box you know and it's
like
you wonder what kind of things are
coming out of that music right
and into the crowd and into you if
you're like you know
identifying with their music and singing
their songs you know well
music itself that's the whole danger
behind it is that
music itself is a conduit of worship and
so what you're singing about what you're
what you're what's in the song the
content of the song
is what you're worshiping and so it ends
up being
that is your new god and so when i was
listening to things like tool and
whatnot
tool actually was one of my hard
argument points for christians
because james maynard's uh testimony of
experience with his
stepfather who was a catholic priest who
molested him oh interesting
well even in a perfect circle in the
song
judith was that what was called yeah
it's been so long now but yeah
it was a song about his mother dying of
cancer and he's like
he's just totally mocking
god or like bashing christ like yes
where's your god now basically right
it's not like you killed someone or
something yeah no that's exactly how the
lyrics
go in that song that was one of those
songs that i kind of
you know didn't resonate with just
because i wasn't about disrespecting god
i
believed god existed still i just didn't
want to follow him anymore that's
interesting
that's an interesting position to be in
so you want you're in the occult
into that darkness and into that world
but you still have an amount of respect
for god
right because he was god and that was
something to me that even as even as
an occultist you were called to have
respect for other people's religions
interesting you know because and but it
was looked at as a different perspective
i eventually moved in with a fella who
was a high magus in the occult and he
started teaching me and my
wife at the time well fiance we never
got married and
that comes later but he started teaching
us about the occult and about the
different practices and
yeah it's really weird when you start
doing things in the sky clad and
everything and you're
in the circle room and you've got
daggers and you've got chalices and
all sorts of you know occult symbology
and just like
start realizing that almost everything
in the occult is connected to each
other's meanings
like astrology was my hard point i used
it as social
as my social tool when i wanted to get
to know people at the coffee house it
was hey what's your sign i know it
sounds cheesy
right but it works people talk
and they're like oh you know and people
people that are less or less christian
were more excited about it so i can
gauge where they were
oh interesting yeah as like a subtle
barometer
right i never thought of it like that
before so it's like i can see somebody
if they're really into their sign and
they know more about it i'm like
this guy's probably a pagan yeah and you
know and they would get interested
because i could tell them about
themselves because i knew about the
science aspects
somebody was like oh i'm a leo i'm like
oh you're a fire signs you have hardcore
leadership skills and you mo
and you know your headstrong and i would
go through the list of these things
and they'd be like wow that is a lot
like me and that that would be the
conversation engager where i could
pull someone over to probably get a
tarot reading what about numerology
are you very into that kind of stuff
numerology see i hated math
so that was immediate out the door for
me i played it into the things for
instance like
when there were numbers around like
particular numbers like for instance
when the clock had all the same numbers
things like that those would be called
wishing hours where you would have a
particular time in that moment
where something had lined up 11-11
yeah and those kind of things also
played into uh played into the
the eastern mysticism of like yoga they
had uh
they had a lot to do with uh things in
kabbalah had a lot of
numerology specifically because it was
jewish right
and how the new numbers and the and the
symbols crossed so
think about kabbalah for a second um you
have these
very interesting crossovers between
you know these are the jewish mystics
right so this is once again
just think about like what christianity
and the deviation of
of of that into the occult has this like
christian
kind of over it's like almost a stepping
stone right right
the cabal is that way as well i mean
there's all this sort of
you know it's not denying the existence
of god so to say it's just
you know framing it in a different way
yeah and
just a you know a side note is that they
have that crossover and it's literally
it's the pre-judean mysticism and that's
that's what the sadducees practiced
and so that's why the sadducees and the
pharisees were you know at odds with
each other
interesting you know one was overly
legalistic no this is the way we're
supposed to do it this is exactly how we
got to do it we got to follow it this
way to the letter
and then the sadducees were the ones
were being like no we've got you know
the universe and with with kabbalah it
was more there wasn't
uh god wasn't like characteristic he
didn't have personality he was
the ultimate source of all good energy
flowing throughout the universe
the astrology and astronomy that's two
different
things right yes yeah the astrology is
is the study of the actual like
mysticism behind
astronomy where astronomy is the study
of the actual stars
like the science behind it
so you're in a band you're getting kind
of further down the road here but you
still got respect for god
i do and uh you know i had at that point
in time
in my musical path i was worshiping
apollo
i was asking for influence from him
apollo and athena were my go-to's at
that time
and those were the ones i respected
because one was justice and law
that was athena and she was the goddess
of warriors
and then you know apollo he was the sun
god
of inspiration and music and so i was
following them like i was
it was all sorts of like nerdy things
that followed with it like i was playing
magic the gathering i was
you know doing like anything that you
could think of that kind of
fell into it i identified with
interesting
interesting and so uh i get to this
point
where i'm doing prosperity spells i'm
doing you know i'm in a group i have
people that know me i have people that
love me i have people
love me and these are the people i'm
getting together with like every weekend
drinking smoking and ritual
and we're doing these rituals and it's
just like you know
how does that come up hey you guys want
to come over to my house for this
weekend we got this cool ritual that
we're gonna do you know like
is that like well see here's the thing
usually it starts with purpose
you have a purpose for doing any ritual
i've got a few people here that need
jobs we need to do a prosperity spell
[Music]
kind of like how all of a sudden we'll
just feel like hey let's go ahead and
pray guys
right right when there's a need there's
a direction because the way that they
describe magic
is you have to have your direction
your emotion and your will and they all
have to line
interesting you can see the counterfeit
because
you know where this is kind of the
separation between magic
and miracles is really you know a
miracle or something miraculously
happening
is really going god you are the creator
of the universe and you control this as
opposed
to i'm gonna do something that's gonna
make this thing happen
right right and it's and it's more about
like you get the
the big head about having the know-how
about knowing how the ritual works about
well i'm familiar with the spirits not
the spirit being familiar with me
and then you don't understand how it
works
but the fallen angels make it work the
way you want to see it
that's right and so it's kind of like
you know where god has the ability to
say this is going to happen i know this
is going to happen because i've seen it
satan has the ability to be like well
he's predicting this is going to happen
so i'm going to send you over there to
make that happen
he's controlling this behind the scenes
right he's
so it's kind of interesting what you're
saying because the law of attraction is
kind of like
kind of like the same i don't know yes
yes very much so like the law of
attraction and the uh
there's another book it talks about the
the art something about power and uh
it was a very manipulative book um i
can't remember the title right now
i'll get back to you on that part but as
far as the way that those all worked
we were studying things out of the
something called the nokian
anokian was supposed to be the musical
and language of the angels
so it was known that throughout kabbalah
that angels spoke
in musical tones and that's why you know
angels
worship because you know music came from
them
and so with that those tones affected
the universe and you could use those
same tones
in your rituals to affect the universe
and manipulate
um reality okay so what
what would that sound like i mean like
if i've stumbled upon
stuff on youtube that's like frequency
and it's just like
right right same concept self-hypnosis
same concept they're talking about how
these frequencies will affect you know
they'll even get into science about it
and how they'll affect the uh you know
the particles around you the energy
within
you know your circle your chakras your
your aura and all of the same things
like the vibrations
and these kind of things are what are
the supernatural things that
actually affect you physically have you
seen those videos where they play music
and there's like sand on the table and
they change the frequency and the sand
makes these cool like
patterns yeah they [__] the shapes yeah
it's crazy
and and you think like you know they've
done some pretty wild experiments well
they've done some pretty wild
experiments with music
and you know if that's going on in the
world what's happening when it's sitting
there
bombarding us right we're 70
water right right and how how sound wave
affects water
right and then you know this has always
been one of my really favorite
favorite theories and you know thoughts
processes behind creation
is that god said let there be light
god said you know and it was created
yeah and to think that there's such a a
powerful and intricately manipulating
sound wave you know because a sound wave
is the only thing that can move
an atom and electrons and manipulate
matter
interesting and so when you think about
that yeah
to manifest matter with the sound wave
right yeah
god's voice right resonating
one very cool uh presentation
series it's like 10 hours long i've
watched the whole thing
the distraction dilemma you can actually
look that up on youtube but
there's a lot of science experiments and
stuff with rats and things like that but
one that i remembered was
it was two two different experiments
with water
freezing and as classical music was
being played over this water it would
freeze into these perfect symmetrical
beautiful designs and then over here
you'd have heavy metal and it was just
jagged and sharp and unproportional
and yeah like you said our bodies are
made up of
water and and why would this look so
beautiful and symmetrical and this would
be so jagged you know i think there's a
lot to that
yeah and with this i was at the peak
of my pagan experience i was
with this group we were practicing
almost every weekend sometimes twice a
week
um i i had no reason to leave i had
every carnal desire i could think of i
had alcohol i had drugs and i had women
and it was just at that point in time
when god decided to throw the kibosh at
me
and i started i hit a hard point where i
couldn't get a job
i hit a hard point where i couldn't make
any money and at this point in time
i was a single father when these things
went down i was still practicing after
the fact after we separated i was still
practicing
and we were doing prosperity spell i'd
do a prosperity spell three days later
i'd get a job
three weeks later i'd lose that job and
so i do believe that numerology did play
into it like i think that those
numbers and i think they all make sense
like universally they have some sort of
meaning
that is happening like friend they say
something about the law of evil they
have to announce
what they do before they do it and so a
lot of times do they believe that that's
what they're doing on tv
yeah the movies the predictive
programming like
seven scenes and then 911 happens or
whatever yeah right like the simpsons
wait a minute like this is this is
somewhat new to me i don't know if i've
heard this before have you heard this
before
that they have to announce the evil the
angels
behind the scenes yeah have to somehow
come out and
and it's just like the bible has
prophecy
okay so they are kind of making their
own
bible prophecy about what they plan on
doing right before they do it it's like
a ritual like a
kabbalah ritual so i believe
there's a lot of evidence to show that
911 didn't happen the way that the media
told you
um that there was actually you know
inside
job into that and uh yeah you do see a
lot of it in
a lot of different forms of media the
music industry i mean you see
uh like for example in the middle of the
nfl what's called uh the halftime show
yeah halftime show
you see all these musicians you know
ladies or something
when you're coming down and it's like i
think what i remember it was madonna and
it was uh somebody else yeah and they
said that
when she dressed whatever and that you
did this it's kind of like a
madonna nightmare i mean she's the queen
of pop now it's somebody else
right right you know they got the rank
got passed down yeah
the crown was given over to someone else
i mean there's a lot of things that are
very strange about them announcing
um those those illuminati cards you ever
seen that and they
actually have like cards well they're
like illuminati cards they look almost
like tarot cards kind of never actually
seen it
it's the playing cards almost like yuya
or something and the concept
the idea of i mean nobody really knows
the truth about it but it was
it was made in the either late 80s early
90s
and people think that it was a an
insider who was trying to get the
message out
so they literally look like pokemon
cards like there's a picture up here and
at the bottom it tells you how much
it's worth or whatever and uh
those cards just keep happening man
talking about from
the twin towers being nuked it shows a
missile hitting the twin towers
it shows the pentagon being hit it shows
the bp
oil spill that's crazy i mean everything
yes people look like alex jones and
everything it makes sense it makes sense
like a lot of because for you're talking
about playing cards like you guys had
opened up in uh
in a controller level two when it talks
about the uh the you know fumey cards
those like i could i could literally do
tarot with playing cards and i used to
when i was off
when i didn't have mine my cards that
were supposed to be familiar with me
right right and so it made
a lot of sense when i seen that and seen
the video game relation and
connected the dots i have a brother of
mine his name is ryan
love you brother and he
made a a connection with his connection
video games he had the same similar
similar uh thing where in zelda when you
showed the uh
the the muslim chant going on in the
fire temple
he before he came to god began praying
to allah and had no idea why
oh wow and then your guy's video kind of
opened that up to him he saw it
yeah that's cool yeah and it really
i mean your guys videos made a big big
hit with like my with my
conversion crazy it was i think like
almost all of them plus
uh scott ritsimo that actually opened
that up to me yeah yeah
and you know my mom brought that all out
and so i was at this low point
and within this low point you know i
could not keep a job
so i had to go swallow my pride and
ask to move back into moms
he was a christian right right and so
she said i could live with her
and immediately all of my siblings
wanted to know about my religion
they wanted to know what i was doing
what i was practicing what it was about
you know is it cool can you control fire
yeah
you know those kind of things because
those are the first things that you get
intrigued by like
hey look you can manipulate fire the
power of it the idea you know it's just
like the idea of the jedis
with the the power of the dark side
and that kind of thing you know and i
started telling them i started teaching
them i actually
did a protection ritual over my sister
when she slept
and she told me that she was scared
because she could see these like
10-foot images in the corner of her room
standing over her
oh wow and they were just dark and
foreboding and and she
and i'm like man i actually called
fallen angels into your room
wow that's nuts and so mom found out
about it
and uh not in my house yeah she said
your son can stay in here
but you have to go stay in the pop-up
camper in the driveway wow
and so i was in the pop-up camper in the
driveway wow and on the third day i
drank myself into a stupor i drank about
750 milliliters of vodka
oh wow by myself with orange juice oh
wow
and i passed out that night and uh
here's where your favorite part comes in
i had a dream and the way that god
speaks he speaks to you in the language
that you understand
that's right so i was out in the middle
of space in the stream
and it was like you ever seen scooby-doo
where they've got the haunted mansions
and it was one of those it was like a
haunted mansion floating in the middle
of this space
and there were other bodies on the
balcony and we were like kind of
in a spiritual ethereal kind of thing
and we were on this balcony
and i look down from the balcony i see
what i pictured as two demons
arguing over who was going to destroy
our souls
yeah yeah skeletal faces they had like
the brown and black robes and had
glowing eyes and sharp fangs
and you know i mean obviously that's not
what they i mean they could look like
that i have no idea
i mean i don't know how far they've
fallen from grace right right
but they said wait one's escaping
and you guys ever seen villain ted's
excellent adventure
remember when they would go through the
time warps that's what it felt like i
was going through
and then it slowed down and i saw a
house
that i had not yet lived in i know now
that i've lived in it
wow it was in alaska
i'll tell you more about that in a
minute but in this dream
have you ever had a dream and then there
was things in the dream that you knew
but there was no evidence of it
yeah so i woke up in the body
of a child i had not yet had wow
i was walking around in my daughter's
body wow and i was looking and i saw my
son
as a teenager and at this point in time
he was only about two
and i saw who i was married to didn't
know who they were but i saw like a
silhouette of them
and i go to open the door or i hear the
doorbell
and i'm like cool i get to see me now
and so i go to open this door
and it all goes black and i hear the
only thing i can say was the voice of
god in my mind
in my heart i felt it like the voice
resonated
within my being and he said the path
that you're on leads to death
wow come to me and i will give you life
wow
and i woke up with a kind of slap you in
the face memory left
and the memory that was in my mind that
i woke up to
was my mother asking me
when i first started she said when are
you going to come back to god
and i said when god comes down and tells
me he wants me back
wow wow and so
wait that conversation happened before
the dream yeah
wow yeah it's amazing that you even
remember the dream considering you drank
yourself to sleep
right right and so uh that day i uh
stopped wearing all of my big baggy
clothes stopped wearing all my makeup
change i cut my hair i dyed it back to
its normal color that day
wow and i called my mom and said we
needed to talk
um and so my mom came and
she wanted to you know my mom said when
my mom tells her part of the testimony
she says that she heard a voice when i
after the phone call it said he's back
and she's like no that's just me that's
just me and wishful thinking
so just granted when i was living there
she had been praying over my room in the
basement every day
laying on the floor praying for me thank
god for mother's day
right praise god and
so that all happened and she's like
yeah he's whatever he's not back yeah
and so she goes to pick me up
and this is what she sees
wow that's impressive
yeah i just changed everything on the
drop of a hat i'm like god wants me back
he asked for me back you did what i said
how can i disrespect that
praise god that's also a testament
to not only a praying mother but you
know
those seeds were planted and that amount
of respect was there
yeah and you know as much as it's
difficult for god to allow us to walk
away from him
it's like he's only when we get to
heaven well you know
how many opportunities god was just
waiting waiting waiting what's the best
time to
to pull him in vam he's got his moment
and he pulls you back in oh often
like when i when i told that story to my
brother paul
paul volk is a he's a health minister
who's who's retired has his own ministry
he does uh
he does a lot of uh the health messages
he's actually
part of my uh my adventist testimony
cool
and he said that what he images when
he's talking to somebody who's having
a difficult time with conversion he says
he pictures their their guardian angel
over their shoulder
saying help me
and it just it drives him it motivates
him to
to try and think of anything that he
could do to like warm this person's
heart to bring him to god
that's awesome and it just you know
since you know then it hasn't been
perfect it hasn't been easy
i got baptized at my mom's church i
started wearing a cross
as part of my testimony and wearing your
witness
right started taking care of you know my
son a lot better because i wasn't out
partying and drinking and smoking and
ritualing and
that's how it ended up being for a while
and then that's when i got full custody
of trevor
nice so you start coming back into the
church you're starting to have a
relationship with god um i know you
kind of have a whole
other side of you because you go into
the military at this point
am i right yeah well when you came home
from the military
um you know did you did you were you
kind of still
one foot in the world one foot in the
church and you know
tell me a little bit about how how this
all ended up how did you get to this
space that you're in there right now
well i ended up going through a divorce
while i was in the desert and uh
the only thing that was keeping me from
you know
i've never been suicidal before until
that point
wow when i was going through that when i
was going through a divorce
and my son was actually being a little
backstory on my son
i had to sign temporary custody over to
my mother while i went through basic
what the recruiter didn't tell me is
that on that paper it wasn't just until
i was done with basic it was for my
entire first term
in the military which is four years and
so
i fought that and i've been fighting it
the entire time
and i didn't get my son back until after
i got back from my deployment
and so my son went from my mother's
to my aunts while he was being taken
care of while i was deployed so i'd get
phone calls and i'd be able to talk to
him every once in a while but him being
you know
three four he didn't really want to talk
to me on the phone he didn't want to do
anything he wanted to
play watch his cartoons play his video
games so he was still into video games
too because video games still hadn't
been brought to that point
where it was you know connected with the
occult and demons
and so uh happy notes we all survived
and then uh i actually gave
my son's mother a second chance when i
got back from iraq we had started
talking while i was in the desert during
my divorce
she was going through a divorce as well
so we we called we went through what we
call our
practice marriages and we got back
together
and this bundle of joy was born
the child that i had not yet had
in the dream so that was the first
prophecy god showed me
because connie for the longest time was
not able to have children doctors
continue telling her she can't have kids
she can't have kids
she'd had relationships prior to me
where she tried to have kids
couldn't do it the first night we were
together
we made lily wow
and that was our happy family at the
time
wow
and so a lot went down since then
i had uh connie and i divorced six
after six years of marriage yeah
and my our my drinking was a significant
part of it
you know i was not i did not try my best
the way i should have
and as a as a christian i was
just deeply uneducated we had we had
been jumping from different churches she
got baptized
when she came to me she was an atheist
the second time
and we spoke and we you know we talked
and we would have
drunken arguments over the bible
[Music]
and uh it got to the point where she
believed that lillian was the miracle
that she needed to believe
because she couldn't have kids and so
the second time god gave her lillian
and she said lillian was the deciding
factor and she got baptisted
and baptized at a methodist church
yeah and so it's like it goes it goes
deep
and so in alaska is where i got divorced
and my divorce
is where i recognized my alcoholism
because
after my divorce it was really easy to
drink really easy to eat anything i
wanted really easy to do anything i
wanted
to kind of numb it numb it and recreate
my
my dad bod to you know something that i
could date with
right right right and i moved out on my
own
and uh connie had physical custody of
lillian
there was some uh discrepancy there
and so throughout that time i had gone
through my dating phase and my mom
had been trying to my mom at this point
in time had been speaking with my sister
who was married and a fourth generation
adventist
at the time they weren't practicing but
when they had gotten together and had
their children they had buckled down
and decided they were going to get right
with god
and so they became very dedicated
adventists
and then from there my mother
came over to adventism he was a catholic
actually my mom was the one going with
me
down the adventure of of uh every
denomination that we could to find truth
oh wow so because when i got baptized
the first time during the testimony i
gave
i was baptized in a non-denominational
kind of pentecostal practicing it's like
you notice that every denomination
actually has a denomination they just
don't like one or two of the rules in
that denomination so they're
non-denominational yeah usually
non-denominational is
baptists who speak in tongues and wear
blue jeans right
right and everything else fundamentally
where pre-trib
and yeah once they've always saved all
that right right and that's what i was
going through that's what
i was first baptized under and so my mom
and i went through that
and then we went from there to a
non-nominal church a non-denominational
church that was practicing uh messianic
judaism
which is where the sabbath came in right
which is where the sabbath got taught
because
they were teaching it and they were like
uh the pastor was convicted
he actually changed from sunday
to friday nights wow he lost a huge
chunk of his uh church
that makes no sense man like when people
say it's just a day it doesn't matter
you can keep any day and then the
congregation leaves because you switch
the day
right right if it's just a day and you
see
the thing is it's convenience because
they work that day
and it didn't make sense to me because
it's like okay do you work that night
because it's in the evening but i
probably did it for
ease of people yeah but that's where i
learned a lot about
the like biblical truth that's when i
started reading my bible and started
actually getting into it
because they gave it to me in
explanations that made
sense because i understood the jewish
culture when it started when he started
explaining to me that
the the plagues were a response
to the gods that they were worshiping
and that each plague
was to kind of show that that god
couldn't protect you
for instance you know when the water
turned into blood in the nile
there was a god of the nile that he was
showing i have power over this
he was and and the way that my pastor
described it at the time it was really
beautiful
he described it as like a husband coming
back for his wife
and showing that all these men that
you're with can't take care of you like
i can yeah
right that's a good point good point wow
dude
so that's powerful so so you start kind
of going through a searching
of the truth but what really solidified
your
walk in the christian faith that you
have now okay
so while i was in alaska when i was
going through this down slide my mom had
been
converted at that point in time she ate
up the amazing facts series just like
like all the food that she ever wanted
and
she did it in like a couple weeks so she
she she crammed like for for an exam
and she's like okay i agree with this
this this works out i agree with this
that that makes sense i can do that
and you know it was just like kind of
like revamping everything like
the truth fit and so
when when she became converted that's
when she started calling me
that's when you know but mom had already
moved to alaska when i first got there
and she saw everything that i went
through with the divorce
and she ended up moving to texas for
other reasons and then coming back to
alaska for my birthday
and because i had the girl that i was
with i was
i was living with a woman who was
already married going through a divorce
and her three kids i had my one
i had my daughter on the weekends and
i had my son and so
i was living in complete abomination
i was still drinking i was still smoking
i was still
you know um just like being together and
not me
right right and and
obviously it wasn't just living together
yeah but
these are the things my mom came and she
explained to me she said
how can god bless you when you know
you're living in sin
and i'm like oh like my heart was just
ripped out and i'm like
i'm like mom you're so right i'm so
miserable
and i started taking little steps in the
direction she was going i said i'm going
to start eating vegan
and i stopped eating unhealthy and
i said okay i'm going to make this right
and so
i was just taking little step by little
step and mom was every morning
walking in prayer with me and praying
in the room next to mine and she would
take time out to go pray and time out to
read her bible
and i was like this is different this is
new this is
this is something i don't have what is
this
and so
it got to the point where she um the
woman i was with was so fed up
with all the different changes and all
the you know things she was she was
getting scared
she said your mom's got 24 hours to get
out of the house um
and i didn't tell my mom that she said
that i came into mom's room i'm like mom
we have 24 hours to get out of the house
wow um yeah there's
that was the breaking point for me where
i said look you can't have
you can't have me if you can't have a
good relationship with my mom
because my mom raised me my mom took
care of me she did everything for me
there is nobody who's going to kick my
mom out
and then expect me to have respect for
them
and so mom's like okay normally
this would be the time where i panic but
i'm not going to panic
i'm going to give it over to god let's
pray and so we prayed together
and i think it was just within an hour
or so of making some calls
she had a place to go wow and i had a
place to go
wow and that place that i had to go was
with paul volk
wow and living in that place that i was
telling you
was my buddy ryan and so i was living
with paul volk and he was like
well there's no meat in my house there
will be worship every day
you will participate i go to church on
the sabbath
you will come to church with me and i'm
like i'm ready for a game changer
how did that even happen how did who
knew him
it was a friend from uh well see
my brother-in-law jeremy he was the
the fourth generation adventist and
this is the part that really really gets
me
before i was an adventist i went and he
asked me to come play guitar at the
church that he was attending
and i went and i played guitar at the
church i did special music for him
and so that church knew paul
and so jeremy got the connection from
that church to paul
and uh when i did become adventist
i started attending that church and i
walked in the door and it had been
years and they remembered my name
that's powerful um i remember
one of the churches when i came from
hollywood
and into the christian faith again
um my wife and i we had just gotten
married
and we started visiting a bunch of
churches around the la area
and you know a couple of them that we
ducked in and out
wouldn't have known if i was you know in
there or not there
and one of the churches um the pastor
walked over to me
and he said i haven't seen you before
what's your name and i gave my name and
he goes can i have your phone number
i was like like seriously like you like
okay
it was awkward but i was like here you
go here's my phone number
after the service i drove away from that
church that pastor called me
and he said hey i just wanted to check
see if you like the service and
and uh had a great time um do you mind
if i save your number in my phone
um because cause we do like bonfires on
the beach and stuff like that and i'd
love to invite you and your wife oh man
wow
and dude i'll tell you what we and it's
the pastor we stuck at that church
same thing happened with my mom my mom
uh
saw me share my testimony at church and
she said
i'm looking for this church when i go
home and she went
and um she said after church the
pastor's wife
said would you mind if i do bible
studies with you and she's like
what do i mind like the pastor's wife is
asking if she can do bible studies with
me
and like she said and when they ate
together the pastor sit next to her
we were going to churches where the
pastor was being escorted out
before anybody like like some celebrity
yeah
like mega churches in the past yeah two
people are like escorting them out and
then you're like where's the pastor i
wanted to talk to him he's uh
if your pastor wears ray-bans
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow usually it was their alligator shoes
that gave him away
seriously michael what a powerful story
so this is your family coming
um into more of a recent picture yep
this is more recent and uh this is in
alaska
i had uh unfortunately i i mean i had
i had given connie another chance after
i became adventist
to even get back together and be like
look this is the lifestyle i'm living
we're not watching
entertainment television we're not
playing video games and she couldn't do
it
yeah i it's sad but
i was very un i was very uh
it was just a sad moment yeah and uh
here's just one last thing my son in the
military
wow falling in his daddy's footsteps
you know he is a combat medic you know
it's very interesting
that you know we
we grow up in this world we think we're
invincible
and we have children and it changes our
perspective oh my goodness
and i'll tell you what i tell people
this all the time if you don't have kids
um it's very difficult to understand
you know when people come up to you and
say i understand god
i understand god a little bit right
right and and when i had my children
it was like this epiphany right at that
moment of just like
i have this incredible love for this
being and then
now yeah unconditional and and all i
want to do is like protect
and and do this and then as my kids have
gotten older
the way that they treat you know me or
the family or anything and you know it's
like
they go through these phases of being
these little selfish things where all
they want is food and i want stuff
and you know it's really changed my
perspective of god
do we treat god like our little children
treat us sometimes do we sit there and
go god give me this give me that come on
help me with this help me with that give
me the job give me this
you know and that's what little kids do
yeah and i think through this experience
of having children as my children have
gotten older i've begun to appreciate
this this amazing god that we have yeah
and so you know as my son i think
follows in my footsteps i actually have
a little plaque
on my wall in my office where my kids
put their feet on there and it
says i want to follow in my dad's
footsteps
and so to me it's neat that you have a
picture here
your son's falling in your footsteps i
know it's not all
roses at this point but like your mother
was praying for you brother
i just want to say there's not a day
that doesn't go by that you don't drop
on your knees and you pray for your
son's salvation you pray for your
daughter salvation and
and trust me god will will penetrate
their hearts
and i pray that someday he's sitting on
the show telling us his testimony as
well amen
praise god praise god we hope you guys
liked today's testimony um this was just
absolutely amazing to hear how god
doesn't leave us alone
i mean no matter where we go what we do
you can see if you could peel back the
curtains of time you would see
god's hand time and time again and how
many
opportunities he's tried to win us back
into the fold and so every time i hear a
story of
of of one of our brethren the sheep that
leaves the sheep pen
leaves the 99 and jesus goes out and
gets that one
and brings him back there's no greater
story than that
so i hope that you guys are blessed by
today's story and
uh if you like this video like it share
it with anybody else you know but
uh thank you for watching we hope you
have a great week god bless
i love anime i love it i mean i can't
watch
enough of this the duelist who they say
can speak with the spirits
the sins will destroy the commandments
forever a suspicious list of names
prompts an investigation at a local
school and concerned from parents the
death note is derived from a japanese
animated show
the girl told authorities she got the
idea from a cartoon network show mom
it's mr satan i recognize that voice
anywhere
[Applause]
[Music]
you